so we are experimenting with the vanduul
physicality and part of that is zero
gravity we're using this this rig which
is a lot bungee on it because I can kind
of move from stations within a spaceship
with a kind of grace avert of a cat with
with a sort of not not completely zero
gravity but with a sense of being able
to move and make big leaps and bounds
with it kind of effortlessly with the
team we had were the guys that the the
rigging for gravity which obviously they
did a really nice job on the zero-g and
so we're using it to sort of do a low G
environment which we were thinking that
the Vandal kingship has and to allow the
soul to move around pretty quickly and
do sort of bigger more alive jobs so it
was fun I was doing it he's so great
with performance capture I mean you know
he's pretty much the guy that wrote the
book on it it's this company we were
working with which is great it's been
great actually really enjoyed it the
team they're fantastic quite feel my
inner thighs anymore but hey all in the
pursuit of art and happiness
so we have hadi circus playing the foal
who ultimately will be the sort of main
antagonist and then we have Patrice he's
playing the AH Cara who is the leader of
the clan good exercise good creative
freedom a bit like being a theatre
workshop lots of fun Patrice's is trying
to find a kind of center for his
character and I'm going to do the same
we can we cooked up the system so we'll
be actually able to see the avatars for
the first time just right now coming up
right now you can actually see if my
character drinking a cup of tea because
all good vandals need a cup of PG tipps
at the end of the day assume that we're
doing is them on the bridge starting the
battle against the UAE fleet
it's a piece of plastic piping covered
with markers and green tape which
represents a very symbolic ceremonial
sword of the vanduul this is the heart
of your ship so it's like it's sort of
like in chunk and everything's gonna
start powering up it will look slightly
more glamorous dangerous and powerful
both Andy and Patrice weren't speaking
English obviously they were speaking
vandal which is a made-up language but a
proper language that was created by
Britain Watkins who's a sort of
specialist in creating languages and
actually does it for film so he's most
recently doing the last couple of Star
Trek's
come langa prayer the earth what is
called constructed language we are good
direction we clean of course you had a
great Andy Serkis yeah the language is
is is very guttural it's kind of not so
ha sounds and it's you know there's a
lot of that going on yeah it's quite
it's quite rich and it's fun to do well
be able to publish the actual language
and people will be able to learn how to
speak it and it has a combination of
spoken words some signs for emphasis and
also they've and all of bioluminescence
all have sort of tone changes based on
mood and stuff like that so it'll be
very cool yes is reppin Andy it's nice
to have got to this point